[Applause]
this
[Music]
if getting through Valentine's Day
teaches us anything it's that love is a
battlefield fortunately there are plenty
of ways to wage war in video games this
week if you want the hottest games
delivered to you on the front lines
every Sunday be sure to hit that
subscribe button let's see what's taking
up arms right now it's been eight years
since we fought the Covenant RTS style
but halo wars 2 is back with a vengeance
the sequel has you fighting the banished
led by the intimidating a tree ox you'll
have to use the rock-paper-scissors flow
of infantry land vehicles and aircraft
to clear the games 13 missions and you
can do it alone or with friends or take
those same friends on and competitive
multiplayer halo wars 2 is coming to
xbox one and pc on februari 21st and
sent it to play anywhere title buying
one version gives you access to the
other and if you're a longtime fan check
out our discussion on the lobby to see
if halo wars 2 is essential to the
series let's trade halos energy swords
for the giant buster swords of berserk
berserk in the band of the hawk takes
the tried and true dynasty warriors
formula and mixes it up with characters
and events from the legendary manga
series fan favorite characters like guts
Griffith and koske can slice and slash
through the four major story arcs there
are too many troops to count but thanks
to the special kill crush action you'll
be able to take out entire squadrons
with a single swing bruiser kragh least
in Japan last year but it's launching
worldwide for ps4 PS Vita and PC on the
21st speaking of games that already
released in Japan east origin launched
all the way back in 2006 the
long-running RPG series has seven games
and this one is a prequel to them all
you can battle demons with three
radically different characters unica
uses axes and great swords Hugo fires
magic from his wand and the claw is a
heavy hitter meant for advanced players
no matter whom you choose you'll be able
to fill
your boost meter during combat and
unleash some seriously powerful attacks
isse origin came to steam a few years
ago but it's finally making its way to
ps4 on the 21st there's a lot going on
at night in the woods you play as
college dropout may Borowski as she
explores the town of possum Springs and
the hidden darkness behind the scenes
that might sound like a teen drama TV
series but it's an adventure game with a
look that's half children's book half
Tim Burton movie you can run and jump
around town but talking to your animal
friends and making story choices is how
you'll spend most of your time and did i
mention that may has paranormal powers
well that's totally a thing to not in
the woods comes to ps4 and PC on the
21st eternal return isn't just a concept
you hear about in philosophy class it's
a super difficult action game you play
as a little night exploring an evil
castle and everything inside once you
dead skeletons swing swords pipe shoot
flames and lasers and a whole bunch of
nasty monsters hang out in the hallways
fortunately you can explore the
different wings of the castle as you see
fit but that won't necessarily make your
quest any easier eternal return comes to
PC on the 24th and those are the biggest
games will be playing this week as
always remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and I'll see you next week
[Music]